our own kellyanne conway is out with a
new book about her time spent in the
trump white house here's the deal a
memoir is a new york times best seller
it's also featured in a new fox nation
special streaming right now
greg your best new york times best
seller you're sitting next to them when
what would you would you be many times
over in fact harold i have at least five
new york times bestsellers but i fire i
lost count actually kellyanne but it is
five
i have a question about
in your book because there's somebody in
your book that is so it's a lying
sociopath and her name is taylor lorenz
and i and this is somebody that keeps
accused she works for the washington
post now used to work for the new york
times she keeps accusing people of
doxing her and stalking her but she kind
of she kind of originated the stalking
and doxing of young people including
your daughter am i right she did she's
made a career out of that and she
doesn't want anybody in her name so
let's repeat it taylor lorenz
she doesn't want anybody to know what
she looks like but she's got pictures
all over the place
look in the summer the late summer and
early fall of 2020 my 15 year old
daughter claudia was doing what lots of
teenagers do pushing back on authority
mom and dad posting tick tocks some of
them were anti-trump tick tocks and tele
lorenz thought it was her job to go and
pull them all together and put them in
front of her 200 000 twitter followers
but she did something else she direct
messaged our daughter in the dead of
night who's 15 whose parents are pretty
easy to find by the way
and she never even bothered to call she
told our 15 year old daughter because
it's all in my official white house
email will be in the archive soon i
guess that she told our 15 year old
daughter if at any time you're
uncomfortable give your mother my number
now would you feel more
at ease if she were a man
direct messaging a 15 year old girl 15
you're not you're not old enough to vote
to probably get your ears piercing an
r-rated movie drive a drink of course
but um this is this is here now she's on
msnbc crying literally crying she's a
peter pan of a female journalist and
there are lots of them but look i you
know you know um
i think we need standards
and i will say that there were many
people in the media who left it alone
there were other people who thought
that the daughter of a staffer was
relevant at the same time they were
covering for a hunter biden 51 year old
grown son grown man of a guy who's now
president they covered for him they let
the other they like the girl trend but
you know my daughter all my kids are
amazing they have more class dignity
discretion judgment in their pinky then
does taylor lorenz and a lot of the
reporters by the way who followed it on
twitter what were they waiting for yeah
to me to say where kovan started yes
me to have this to finally do you think
in my pocketbook there was russia
collusion at last greg and claudia can
go in there and get it so um they were
disgraceful and even though i'm a
christian who grants mercy and
forgiveness routinely i will not forget
or forgive some of them it wasn't just
tale of the friends there are lots of
other reporters i've never revealed and
i will in good time because claudia
shared those messages with me hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else